TANESHIA RICE: Just Nesh.
KEVIN HART: Chicago native.
- Yes
What would the Chicago
people say about Just Nesh?
Very honest.
KEVIN HART: OK.
They always start
off with that.
Very real.
OK.
- Semi-alcoholic.
- Semi--
But--
Semi.
TANESHIA RICE: --I'm functional.
Functional.
Semi.
I think I got voted one of
the top 5 drunkest comedians.
Really?
I didn't appreciate that.
TANESHIA RICE: Yes!
OK.
Well, congratulations.
TANESHIA RICE: Thank you!
That's a-- that's a big honor.
What was it that happened
that you said, you know what?
This is what I'm going to do
with my life, with my career.
This is what I want.
I think the feeling that I got
when I finally start doing it.
I never even planned
on being a comedian.
Did you poo?
I probably burped
a little bit.
You know, I was drunk.
That's how I got on stage.
Thank you, Grey
Goose, for my start.
But no.
Yeah, I'd never planned
on being a comedian.
My friend made me
go up one night
because everybody was bombing.
She was like, you could do that.
I'm like, oh, yeah,
I could bomb better.
What?
I gotta bomb better.
I'm gonna bomb better.
And I got up there
and I just loved it.
It was amazing.
It was an amazing feeling
making people laugh.
I don't think anything
that I've ever done
in my life compares to that.
And I just kept going back
and then it's like, crap.
It's like, I gotta.
I gotta go make somebody laugh.
I gotta!
So.
And that's how I knew.
I was--
- If none of you--
--addicted to it.
--have ever taken
crack, this is
as close as you'll get to it.
So get on stage
and feed that drug.
Give it to your system.
You just start a reaction.
It goes, I gotta have it!
Is amazing, you'll love it.
Just Nesh, are we ready
for "The Next Level?"
We are so ready.
Been ready.
Too ready.
- OK.
Stop wiggling.
What is this?
Just Nesh!
Thank you so much.